are you in the of the belief that Kevin
Durant the Knicks is a quote unquote
done deal I don't have anything to done
deal because ultimately the Knicks have
to sit in the room with them and the
Knicks have historically been just bad
when they do that they you know you go
back to 2010 with all the free agent
mating meetings they took they were not
impressive in those meetings and yes
it's a a new group and Scott Perry is
leading it Steve Mills is there but what
happens if James Dolan gets in the room
and screws it up I mean it it's possible
it's possible but all right you know
like everybody else rich I've been
hearing all along that strong leanings
for Kevin Durant go to York and I just
can't believe the Knicks would be crazy
enough it's crazy as I've been in the
last two decades crazy enough to just
give away kristaps porzingis unless they
knew that there was a high chance to get
Durant and a pretty good chance they get
to ranted somebody else for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app